- Everybody poops, dude.
That girl you really like? She poops.
That guy you like? She poops.
Your dad? He poops!
Your dog? He poops!
So why aren't we talking about poop more?
(cheerful synthesizer music)
- This next week I will be
pooping using the Squatty Potty.
I have heard about the process
of squatting while pooping
being the proper form.
- We're pooping like this, and it's like,
hard for the poop to
come out of our butts,
when really we should
be pooping like this.
It's one of those products
I've always wanted to try,
but low-key I'm kind of,
I don't want to say embarrassed to try,
but like, timid to try?
- I would really love to
streamline the process.
I'm a very busy person.
- In a given poop session, I go through
like 30 different sheets of toilet paper.
That's what I'm hoping to get out of this,
is an easy cleanup.
- If I can find a better way to poop,
maybe that might bring me more peace.
- Poop better!
- All right, man, I'm ready
to take you to my poop palace,
and let's see if you bring me some peace.
- [Clark] ♪ bummmmmmm, bummmmm, ♪
♪ Bummmmmmm, bummmmmmmmmm! ♪
- Just shittin' on the toilet.
I mean, sittin' on the toilet.
- All right, my feets are elevated,
it's time to begin.
Am I vlogging while I'm poopin'? Yep.
Is it weird? No.
I mean, you see dogs
poopin' on the street,
and it's totally fine.
- Live update, that was an awesome poop.
Usually it takes me a while,
constipation is a real thing.
- I honestly, I'm already done pooping.
That took like 20 seconds.
- Not to be graphic, but it
just came right outta there.
Just slid on down.
- It was a smooth process.
Just because it's not common for us,
it makes it feel a little awkward,
having to like put up your feet
after you sit on the toilet.
- My bowels are empty,
and my heart is full,
because the poop was
fast, cleanup was easy.
- First poop, successful.
- Day two, I just took another
poop on the Squatty Potty,
and honestly, I had
better luck the first day.
- Too much information alert.
One thing I'm realizing is I feel like
it lets a lot more poop out? (laughs)
- So I just went to the bathroom,
and I tried to not use the Squatty Potty,
just at the beginning,
just to see, you know,
if it was the placebo
effect, to see if like,
oh, it's shiny, it's new,
it's helping me poop!
But let me tell you, I
was sitting on the toilet
for 30 minutes before anything happened.
Slid that puppy right under my feet?
Smooth sailing.
- Squatty Potty has been
used even by my guests
that come to my house.
- She had her first Squatty Potty poop.
How was it?
- Better than expected.
I would say it did help me poop,
but I did almost die getting on.
- I'm thinking that
maybe by the way that it
angles your legs, helps
you to release more,
which I would assume is
probably a really good thing.
- I feel like day three
might be a little bit better.
- I got a report, poop number three...
was awesome!
- Sittin' on the toilet.
Nothing's happening.
- Guys, I used the Squatty
Potty this morning,
first thing, you know, just
for a little early load-out,
it was perfect, man.
- It just didn't happen today.
- I do have some disappointing news.
One thing that I was
really hoping with this
is that it would make wiping easier,
but I think that was just
my delusional optimism.
Because poop's still coming
out, and you still gotta wipe.
So I think I just need to
finally admit I'm a damn adult,
and I need to learn how to wipe my butt.
- I just really wanna poop, man.
- That was a beautiful experience.
It was just like pressing
an eject button on my butt.
- I'm getting used to it.
I don't think it's odd anymore.
I actually like going to the bathroom now,
and using the Squatty Potty,
even when I'm not pooping.
- The Squatty Potty has
gotten my poop time down
at least 15 minutes.
- My bathroom is pretty tiny,
and I like the fact that
I can slide it in between
my toilet and my sink.
- Poo number four was great.
Decided to use it for
the rest of the week.
Just finished poo number
five, it was fast,
easy, clean, and dare I say fun?
- When I was at work today, I had to poop.
I found myself looking
for a Squatty Potty.
- You really can't beat
those efficient poops.
Like I'm in and I'm out!
- I just kept it all together,
and just waited til I got home.
Wasn't the best idea, but you know what?
I went for it, and I'm so glad
that I had the Squatty Potty here.
Honestly, day five, I'm
more grateful than ever
that the Squatty Potty
has been gifted to me.
- Um, and yeah, this video isn't
sponsored by Squatty Potty.
It's just sponsored by a
guy who really wants you
to have the best poop health that you can.
- I'm going to the Squatty Partay,
you goin' to the Squatty Partay,
we goin' to the Squatty Partay!
(laughs)
(folk music)